hello welcome to science last week from
science mission I am sadashiva pi and
going to discuss few interesting papers
published in the week of March 31st
let's start another protein thought to
be involved in Huntington disease has
been identified in the Nature
Neuroscience paper by dr. budget cuts
lab this paper demonstrates that clear
4.1 potassium channel contributes to
Huntington disease in mouse model
hashtag iosys is seen in the symptomatic
ages that is p62 p80 in our 62 mouse
models of Huntington disease author
showed that there is no ashtabula OSIS
in this mouse model at the symptomatic
gauges here are the data to support
their claim site of gfap immunostaining
was indistinguishable in our 62 mouse
model versus wild-type mouse at p62 p80
ages no detectable morphological changes
associated with the classical
astrogliosis is seen between the mouse
model and the white type mouse Western
blot analysis of the striatal tissue
also showed no evidence for increased
gfap expression so HD like symptoms in
Mouse occur before the overt
astrogliosis according to this data
author see altered properties in
striatal astrocytes and potassium
currents in HD Mouse significant
difference in the resting membrane
potential and conductance was observed
in the astrocytes at the symptomatic age
between the mouse model and wild-type no
difference at the non symptomatic age of
peace 30
also significant difference in barium
sensitive potassium currents attributed
to kill 4.1 potassium channel currents
in astrocytes between the symptomatic
and why type mouse but not at ages that
were pre-symptomatic these results
indicate changes in the potassium
channel currents happen at the same time
as altered conductance properties in
astrocytes what is the cause for
potassium channel conductance changes
author found that potassium channel mrna
levels were significantly altered and
experiments with cultures showed that
mutant huntingtin did not directly
affect kill 4.1 and channel function but
there was reduced level of potassium
channel proteins in the shattered tissue
from the r6 mouse at p62 p80 but not at
the age of p30 although reduced training
of potassium channel observed in the
same astrocytes as mutant huntingtin
reduction in potassium channels were not
attributed to mutant huntingtin since it
had no effect in on the potassium
channel properties in the cell culture
experiments author showed that astrocyte
deficits were restored by viral delivery
of care 4.1 gfp culture transfected with
kill 4.1 showed restoration of
immunostaining also astrocyte resting
membrane potential and microscopic slope
conductances of r62 mouse was back to
control levels by expressing potassium
channels
in addition potassium channels currents
as measured by barium sensitive currents
were restored to normal levels by 4.1
kill 4.1 gfp delivery so expression of
potassium channels restored conductance
properties of astrocytes does Huntington
symptoms were also rescued by expression
of potassium channel gfp let's see what
the data says this figure shows total
restoration of extracellular potassium
resting membrane potential and partial
restoration of membrane conductance in
4k or 4.1 gfp r62 mouse also care 4.1
gfp rescues footprint abnormalities and
improves life expectancies of our 62
mouse delivered with kill 4.1 gfp so yes
Huntington symptoms could be rescued in
the mouse models so this is an
interesting paper adding new tish to the
Huntington disease next the this paper
demonstrates the use of per file in
phospholipid liposomes to target drugs
to directly to the cancer site and
release them using near-infrared light
this is an interesting paper from
Jonathan lavelle slab published in
Nature communications to prevent the
side effects of cancer treatment
delivery of drugs directly to the tumor
is considered one of the options by many
researchers it is challenging to develop
a nano carrier that is that in
physiological conditions can stably
retain cargo in the absence of an
external stimulus but release it in its
presence dr. Lovell slab developed a new
method
for trigger drug release that makes use
of power firing phospholipid p or p
doped liposomes that overcomes some of
the limitations authors examine two
phospholipids pyro lipid one and HP pH
lipid H people H lipid had long alkyl
side chain and monomers might form by
layers with superior self-assembly and
packing properties HP pH was selected as
it is the only simple derivative of pyro
but it is also has been safely used in
numerous human clinical trials stable
cargo retention from by layers of HPP
lipid but not pyro lipid is shown in
this figure this indicates HP pH lipid
meets the requirement better than pyro
lipid next authors looked at the
stability of the liposomes and release
of the cargo the Left figure shows in
the absence of laser irradiation the
solution temperature remained constant
and there was no cargo release in the
right figure liposomes were exposed to
irradiation and cargo was released
steadily and completely over the course
of three minutes release from POV
liposomes occurred without any
significant increase in the solution
temperature this figure shows a laser
mirror in the laser mediated cargo
release into the agarose with the high
spatial control these results indicate
liposomes are stable and release of
cargo at the required place
author shows spatial and temporal
control of cargo release in this figure
gentamicin was loaded in POV liposomes
and embedded in ha tiger along with the
bacteria the indicated spot was
irradiated with laser release of
gentamicin selectively kills the
bacteria around the laser irradiated
sighs finally to demonstrate this
technique works in vivo mice were imaged
following intratumoral injection of
either free sulphur rhodamine B or
sulphur rhodamine B and trapped in POV
liposomes laser activation resulted in
temporal release of the cargo as shown
in this figure so this article
demonstrate a powerful technology for
control release of the drugs and if
proved to work in humans would add
tremendous value to cancer treatment
next look let's look at an interesting
paper entitled short peptide
self-assembled to produce catalytic
amyloids this article was published in
Nature Chemistry by I once group and
talks about how small peptides could
self-assemble into amyloid fibrils and
catalyzed reactions this article has
wide range of implications especially in
neurodegenerative diseases were in short
peptides form tangles and thought to be
responsible for the onset of diseases
let's look at some of the data several
peptides were designed and model of one
of the most active peptide called
peptide 11 is shown here the next figure
shows computer modeling of the five will
formed by 11 here is the same peptide in
overall fold packing of the hydrophobic
core and zinc primary coordination
sphere
here we will discuss some of the data
showing peptide characterization and
demonstration of the requirement of
fibril formation for the enzyme activity
peptide 11 showed better esterase
activity then add other peptides in this
figure paper also looked at the pH
effect and the requirement of zinc for
the esterase activity of peptide 11 CD
spectra of various peptides showed that
peptide 11 had better beta sheets and
dialysis had no effect on the esterase
activity since the active fibrils could
not pass through the filter peptide 11
also showed fibril optimal fibril
formation and the best activity compared
to other peptides finally this figure
showed that the peptide 11 forms amyloid
fibril immediately after synthesis
compared to peptide seven this data
confirms authors claim that peptides
could form beta sheet at five rails and
bring about enzyme activity and this is
an important finding and may have
far-reaching implications finally let's
look at in nature genetics paper by
phillip frugal slab this is the first
time anyone has linked directly
carbohydrate metabolism to obesity the
team did complex and technically
challenging work to evaluates a library
and pancreatic amylase copy numbers in
almost 3,000 people and compared with
the amylase expression amylase activity
and BMI what they found was increased mi
less copy number was positively
correlated with amylase gene expression
and the serum enzyme level which is not
shown here also reduced amylase copy
number was associated with increased BMI
and
obesity risk this data clearly shows for
the first time the link between
carbohydrate metabolism and obesity
although the reason for decreased copy
number is not clearly understood this is
an interesting finding and would have
far-reaching implications thank you very
much for watching science / to